so if nipsey's passing can bring that
many people together who would usually
be on site with how do you keep that
energy going does everyone just need to
smoke DMT man that's the problem bro
like
because that's cool everyone that comes
together for a day but then what happens
like two weeks later exactly right six
minutes later you know honestly we just
need people that are more like Uncle nip
like you know what I mean like we need
more people like that that can really
lead youth in a positive different
direction you know what I'm saying like
I hate to say it but you know the little
like what's some little dudes names a
little like uh a jungle Stone whatever
you know what I'm saying maybe it's not
gorillas whatever the [ __ ] that is not
it bro like that that that
type of energy that's the [ __ ] that that
hold us back you know what I mean and uh
I have to say like bro like like that
type of [ __ ] is
it needs to be redirected because
obviously like like a lot of these kids
got talent and all that but they putting
it in into the wrong [ __ ] you know what
I mean yeah I mean I had them on come up
here and freestyle and they seem like
nice kids you know but I mean they're
kids though yeah but that's what I'm
saying there's like uh growth involved
in all that but I feel like we need like
more like ogs and like not even OG's
like geez like nip you feel me like more
people need to set an example in fact
this is what we trying to push man we
ain't on that type time like you know I
mean like more people have to speak up
and stop trying to be cool and just fit
in with everybody else and copy what
everybody else is doing and really just
like be like true to themselves and say
like hey this is the type of music that
we doing like like the the the music
culture in
the LA has been changing a little bit
because the artists like a blast and
Abino and [ __ ] like that exactly like I
feel like that's kind of that's that's
also helping you know what I mean
because it kind of a Roddy Rich it kind
of shares a Different Light
two even like some of the like like the
one take Jays of the world yeah exactly
like those guys are like not necessarily
letting politics get in the way exactly
that's what I'm saying and I feel like
the younger kids at least most I mean a
lot of the younger generation of La rap
they seem to be more united than I've
seen previous generations maybe because
they're not as a like a heavily
Affiliated and then even the artists
that are you know like obviously there's
artists that don't [ __ ] with each I just
saw the baby Stone guy in the ASM
bobster guy going back and forth on
Instagram I'm like Jesus Christ
um but yeah I just think that like you
said man it takes
you know
I think some some of it's generational
but you know I think it takes like those
homies like yeah that's really like it's
like you know uh I'm sure you got a guy
like Wiz who has put his arm around you
who probably has seen your whole
oh I ain't gonna lie bro you were
hanging out with him when you were on
some [ __ ] osbs I ain't gonna lie bro
that's that's that's my big brother I
can't give enough thanks to him for
really like bro where's like really like
took my took my whole mindset and was
like nah bro like this is what you need
to to be on type [ __ ] right like for
for a while like I ain't gonna lie like
at first when he used to talk to
SmackDown like oh man like I know what
I'm doing type [ __ ] but then when I
really like listen it was him and like
uh and Chevy really yeah that like
caused me to go through this little like
uh and I'd already like went through a
change as a human but like with my with
my music I feel like they helped me be
more comfortable with just being like
true to myself right what I mean being
more like open and honest in my music
and uh like you can't you can't you
can't trade that
mentorship and artists like development
for anything you know what I mean like
where's
executive produced my whole project with
me spent hundreds of hours on my [ __ ]
you know and you're on the new project
with him yeah
I got like three songs on there I got
two with me whiz and uh
MP fire I got one with uh me whiz and Ty
dollar sign too fire and uh it's just
like people like that
just even giving you a [ __ ]
opportunity right coming from what I
come from bro it's like that [ __ ] don't
happen you know what I mean yeah I think
uh a lot of people don't have that that
opportunity to have somebody like whiz
in there like to be like hey that's what
you should be doing